can we go back to
larry cohen yeah can we just
i the things i feel when i listen to
hallelujah by leonard cohen or
anything by him really but that one what
do you want to get into
let's go what what does it that song
mean to you
is it love oh boy well first of all it's
it's
it's mystery like it starts off about
mystery
so what do you what are you doing you're
doing this alternation
between the two chords so three notes at
the same time
one is called the the tonic
or you have the the major and the
relative minor and he's alternating
between them
there's only one note of difference
between those two chords one of them
would be
feeling sad one of them would be more
joyous typically described
and so by altering one note it's the
minimal amount to take you back and
forth between joy and happiness
uh as that's encoded in us so he starts
off with it i heard there was a scene
david played the please a little bit you
don't really care for music do you
um that's really interesting because
it's he's using this technique called
bathos
right so the alternation between the
sublime
and kind of the guttural or ridiculous
or the mundane right
so he's like uh there's a bitterness to
it too
is it just play well the way i hear it
again you know great song allows for
different interpretations you happen to
be asking me so i'm going to impart some
stuff that probably isn't in the song
but why it speaks to me and that's what
makes it great
um the way i hear it is he doesn't
believe the audience you don't really
care for music do you then what are you
doing listening to this you stupid
idiots
you know first you of course you care
for music you're too cool to care
so i see through you and screw you
that's like the kind that's that's the
energy i get
then he does this weird thing it goes
like this is where he should put the
description
of where he is in the chord progression
which is the tonic right
it goes like this and then he hits the
fourth and the fifth
which are the two other major elements
the subdominant and the dominant
in functional harmony so he's describing
the chord progression
in real time in the lyrics there's two
ways this can come about in other
songs like we had this example of
um every time we say goodbye do you know
the song
every time we say goodbye no i think it
was a
cole porter maybe or gershwin maybe
porter i don't know
i cry a little there is no love song
finer but how strange the change
from major to minor right like it's
beautiful
then then there's times when it's
duplicitous so for example you'll have
um i guess my favorite examples of this
are johnny cash's ring of fire
i fell into a burning ring of fire then
what does he do with the
lyrics in the tune
i went down down down he goes up
yeah right and so the idea is like oh
okay that was a head fake yeah
right and another one of these um you
know is nina simone's
feeling good oh okay so what do you get
a
bird's blind hi
you know how i feel and sun
up in the sky high you know how i feel
that woman's voice she doesn't give a
damn
and yet she's feeling but then what's
the duh
yeah it's like heavy stripping music
it's it's
you're not in a good place you're
probably in some strip club
with some last of your money you're
drinking lousy beer
some bad situation yeah and she's
feeling good
no it's funerial it's oppressive right
i never thought of that song that way
wow
well you think of it as joyous yeah no
no if you think about it contrast it
with ray charles for example you know do
you know do you know lonely avenue
well my room has got two windows
but the sunshine never comes through
it's really depressed
it's the same sort of vibe as nina
but she's claiming that she's in great
shape so she's like a good case of the
unreliable narrator
leonard cohen to me is talking about the
unreliable audience that's too cool to
be with the performer on stage
the things that go with the music like
the cole porter stuff they go against
like the johnny cash
i think these are the games that
musicians play that the rest of us
only sort of notice subliminally okay
fourth the fifth then he when he he
should say something about the relative
minor or the
he's giving you the secret the baffled
king in other words he doesn't know why
it works
did paco bell know why pachelbel's canon
would work
yeah it was a discovery that's the whole
thing like some music
is discovered and some music is invented
and he's talking about a musical
discovery he's talking about the
pythagorean power
of the wave equation and then
superimposed like there's two
genius intellectual concepts behind
music one of which is the wave equation
usually we solve it for a
one-dimensional medium because we're
talking about strings or air columns
occasionally
you're talking about things like hand
pans or steel drums or metallophones or
gamalons whatever
and those have a wave equation too
that's much
more chaotic the other equation is this
crazy thing
that 2 to the 19 12 is almost exactly
equal to 3 which is what gave us even
temperament
and so the tension between those two
things is in fact
one of these most beautiful stories
inside of that system
that formula of the baffled king is a
discovery it's not
he's not really composing it the reason
he's baffled it's
imagine that you took like a little
brush and you started brushing off uh
you know a pyramid under the sands
you might think that you created the
pyramid by your brushing but in fact if
somebody else did it that's why you're
baffled
right that's beautifully played you're
right and it's as as
creating one of the greatest songs of
all time and as he's doing it
he's baffled and he's in his mouth
within the song and he leonard is
baffled is my my contention but he knows
enough to know that he's baffled
right and so the idea is that he is
composing he has the audacity
to compose as david
he's echoing david at a minimum and then
in a later song which i really wish we
would discuss that's
totally dystopic and you will not like
it at all
is the future which contains this line
that i
i think i used in my episode with roger
penrose on the portal
uh note the subtle plug the portal the
portal
i'm the little jew that wrote the bible
so there is this way in which leonard
cohen i think is constantly coming to
the idea of being
a biblical-like scribe and i think this
is one of the great things that you know
you see dylan doing this with all along
the watchtower you saw warren zivan who
we should talk much more about
doing this with a song called i was in
the house when the house burned down do
you know this thing
no this is embarrassing sweetheart
that's a great day
warren zevon is one of the most
important songwriters of our time
and he's been largely forgotten
uh by this generation but you know bob
dylan
uh would sing one of his songs in
tribute i've heard bob dylan
you know very small number of
songwriters really move him
woody got three gordon lightfoot
and uh warren zevon by the way bob dylan
if you're out there
appear on either one of our podcasts we
need to get your voice into a new medium
for a new group
definitely this is a time this is a time
for bob dylan my friend
you